- But I hear that you have teeth crushes,
which I find so oddly intriguing.
- Okay, let me explain.
I think it might be because
I've had Invisalign twice,
I had braces for my whole childhood.
- My gap came back.
Whatever.
- I know, I need to start
wearing my retainers.
My dog keeps chewing them.
- Uh, that happened to me.
- I'll wear them in
the middle of the night
and somehow I wake up and they'll be,
my dog will be chewing them.
So in my sleep I take out my retainers.
- In your sleep you
make out with your dog.
- Too much information.
Maybe.
I mean.
(Kelly laughs)
Kind of (laughs).
- My dog's great too.
- No.
But I just like, I love teeth.
I have a fascination with teeth.
I love smiles.
It's like the first thing
I notice about people.
Is that weird?
Kind of.
- No.
Especially with certain actors
too, like Julia Roberts,
I always think of her mouth--
- We love a Julia Robert's smile, yes.
- Do you think if we showed
you some famous teeth
you could maybe give us the lowdown?
- Sure (laughs).
- Okay, here you go.
Let's see some teeth.
Here's the first, Cardi B.
- Oh yes.
- Oh my god, they're so white.
- Symmetrical, white.
Anything Cardi does though, I love her.
She can do no wrong.
- She's hilarious.
- Have you had her on the show?
- I have not, but we met.
We were both performing at this event
and we just happened to
be passing each other
and I was like, "Oh, hey Cardi,"
and she went, "Oh my god,
it's Kelly Clarkson."
(laughter)
I was like, we could be friends
just from this energy moment.
- I love it.
- She's super sweet.
- She's great.
Okay, yes, we approve.
- What do you think of somebody--
Oh, there we go.
Post Malone.
- I have a crush on Post Malone.
- Oh my god, who doesn't?
Musically speaking as well.
- It works.
Anything he does, it all works for me.
- Yeah, and he has, I feel
like, the sweetest eyes.
- He's very nice.
He's very nice.
- He was very nice.
He met my eldest daughter
and he was so nice to her.
- Yeah.
- How about someone with
a diamond on their tooth?
- Okay.
See, that's like very good.
I love Drake.
- It's a subtle diamond.
- Yes.
We like his teeth as well.
- Yeah, I like them too.
I just love that.
I would never want to put
a diamond in my tooth.
- I don't know if I've
ever seen him smile.
Oh, he's got a diamond.
I thought that was a crack on the TV.
(audience laughs)
That is a diamond.
- That's a little diamond.
Well, then maybe he was cheap
and needed a bigger diamond (laughs).
- Do you just like drill a--?
- I guess.
I'm not about that.
I don't like dentists.
The only thing I like about dentists
is that laughing stuff they give you.
(audience laughs)
- He's just like, "I am rich.
I am putting a diamond on my tooth."
- I'm like, "Nah, I'm good."
But I like it.
It's flashy.
I like it all right.
So what about a gap like Madonna?
- I actually love that.
I love them when you embrace
what makes you quirky.
- What make you, you.
It's like when people get
nose jobs all of a sudden.
Like whatever, do you.
But then you lose you and
you look like other people.
I'm like, "Aw, man."
- Yeah, I'm all is support of like--
- I love a gap.
Well, I have a gap, so
that's why I love it.
- Do you?
- Hm hmm.
- I'm going to have one if
I don't wear my retainers.
- I know.
I wear mine.
They just, I don't know.
My tongue is strong.
Anyway--
(audience laughs)